Це є Радомишль. Радомишльський гурт «Релікт».
І вони будуть ще грати, якраз після вечері.
Це вони тільки готуються.
Це є справжній фестиваль.
Але не для себе самого.
Тобто для себе самого, але водночас і для тих, хто приїздить.
Я не хочу казати, що це показ. Це не є шоу.
Але це є можливість того, що світ прийде до нас.
Не ми йдемо до світу, а він йде до нас.
І вони знаходяться в наших джерелах [місцинах],
де ми проводимо наші табори і тренування.
Чому Крячківка? Тут є дерево, тут є тиша, тут ізоляція.
Я вибираю когось, кого я знаю, і співаю його ім'я.
Наприклад, я співаю його ім'я і міняюся з ним місцями.
Дуже просто заспівати.
♪ Катя... ♪
♪ Живосил, Живосил, Живосил, Живосил... ♪
[лунають дзвоники бубенців]
Так, зараз будемо згадувати кого я запам'ятав.
Моя найкраща робота, остання робота. Це все тут.
Так, останні [інструменти] —
бандура, торбан, кобза, панська бандура.
Тут, де Полтавщина, ми готуємо інструменти так,
щоб було гарно: найкращі зразки. Я витрачаю на це час.
Останні може й 20 років: так, щоб дійсно володіти
трохи інструментом — торбан, кобза, бандура.
Але два роки тому я зробив великий крок.
Я взяв свої інструменти, придбав
квиток на літак, поїхав до США
і через фейсбук спитав, чи хтось хоче
[потрапити на] безкоштовний концерт.
[лунає інструментальна музика, жінка співає]
Хто може мене слухати півтори години?
Хто буде це слухати, так?
А люди кажуть: «Вау, це дуже цікаво, дуже дякую!
Ми просто сказали,
але там були дійсно такі натхнення!»
Коли я сам поїхав на інший кінець світу
з інструментом без нікого
і розказав хто я, чим я займаюся і що таке кобзарство,
що за культура мала місце раніше...
І я зрозумів, що не можна цей показ взяти закордон.
Тут в Україні ніколи не забувають,
бо закордоном теж є праця, важлива праця.
Але якщо я забуваю про свою територію —
Полтащина, Україна...
Тому я потрошку почав влаштовувати фестивалі.
[англійською] У Бітлз була пісня зі словами:
[англійською] «Українські дівчата вразили
всіх наповал, вони залишили Захід позаду».
[англійською] Мені подобалися Бітлз і ця пісня,
але я не дуже то й багато знав про Україну.
[англійською] Коли я навчався у коледжі, у стоматологічний
кабінет мого батька, де я працював, прийшла дівчина.
[англійською] І вона каже:
«О, а я знаю дівчину з бібліотеки, Христя Фединскі».
[англійською] Вона її, звісно ж, так не назвала,
вона казала «Крістін». «Чи хотів би ти побачитись із нею?»
[англійською] Я відповів:
«Окей, добре… О, вона українка? Окей»?
[англійською] І ось я пішов на побачення із Христею,
потім ми одружилися, у нас народилися Марко, Юрій, Андреа.
[англійською] І це стало початком мого українського досвіду.
Я хотів, щоб бабуся і мама приїхали.
Бабуся померла, мами ще немає [тут].
А тут тато приїхав. І не просто приїхав,
а коріння пускає.
[англійською] Ми побудували це, бо я подумав,
що воно могло б мати багато застосувань.
[англійською] Найголовніше — це укриття,
де можна було б їсти.
[англійською] Інше призначення —
воно могло б стати укриттям для музикантів.
[англійською] Але будівельники не дуже розуміли,
що саме це має бути.
[англійською] Тож я сказав: «Коли мене не буде вдома,
я тут машину залишатиму, це буде гараж».
[англійською] І вони відповіли: «О, гараж, оце вже зрозуміло».
То перша назва цього була «гараж».
[англійською] Юрій полюбив українську
культуру, українську музику.
[англійською] А після трагедії 11 вересня він зрозумів,
що не може більше жити у Нью-Йорку:
[англійською] «Я хочу поїхати у велике місто,
але не в Америці, хочу поїхати в Україну».
[англійською] То ж він вирішує вивчити українську,
приїхати до Львова, де в нього був далекий родич,
[англійською] дядько – брат Юрка Фединського старшого, —
який, до того ж, більше 40 років
[англійською] грав у Львівському симфонічному оркестрі
на басу. Можливо він це й досі робить, я не знаю.
[англійською] Коли він приїхав до Києва, він почав проявляти
більше зацікавленості у наших відносинах та зв’язку між нами,
[англійською] він хотів почати навчання у виші –
у Київській музичній консерваторії.
[англійською] Він завжди всім обходився самостійно,
або інколи йому бабуся допомагала – Наталка Фединська.
[англійською] Я погодився, хоча мені і не вистачало стосунків
із ним, я дозволяв йому дистанціюватись, якщо він того хотів.
[англійською] Це і є фактична історія.
Ми запросили його [приїхати].
[англійською] Коли ми знов зустрілись, то ми з Юрієм
відправились до Нью-Йорку, щоб купити деякі інструменти.
[англійською] Лише за гроші в Україні нічого не зробиш.
[англійською] Але якщо ти наполегливий, і в тебе є
трохи грошей, то ти можеш досягти багато чого.
[англійською] Особливо якщо проєкт
ще комусь потрібен і ти ним захоплюєшся.
[англійською] Мій батько – дуже хороший
учасник команди. Відмінний навіть.
Я хочу вам передати такий сюрприз з Одеси.
— О, Одеса.
— Це херес.
— Херес? А шо це?
— Херес — це вино.
— Давай, мила, дітям. Скільки дітей в тебе?
— Чотири поки.
— Чотири, давай чотири.
— Чотири, клас.
— У нас три.
— У нас тільки троє.
Поступово.
[сміються]
Детонічна бандура двадцятих чи тридцятих років.
У дуже доброму стані.
— Ой, таки...
— Диви, в якому вона доброму стані.
Це щось неймовірне.
Розумієш, але тут у мене через те,
що це дерево, треба —
і тут тоже потріскалось —
треба вирізати, вставити вставку, мабуть.
— Клас, серйозний інструмент.
— Вирізать, вставить вставку мабуть, да?
— Дійсно гарний стан.
— Звук потрогай, послухай.
[награє простеньку мелодію]
Тут має бути певний фільтр, я зрозумів.
Сюди тільки серйозні люди приїжджають.
Несерйозні [люди] сидять вдома.
І це початок кобзарського шляху.
Ти можеш йти три кілометри пішки.
Тоді може і у вас буде кобзарський шлях.
От це я мріяв два роки: як приїду до Юрка,
то зроблю [інструмент] як не собі, то хоч комусь.
І тут Чайка мені підвернулася.
Каже: «Їжджай сюди на рубікон. Не пожалкуєш».
Цей інструмент, каже, їй приснився у вигляді птаха.
Я кажу: «Добре, поїдемо. Я допоможу».
Я столяркою сам займаюся 25 років.
Тільки ж я станком володію,
а не таким інструментом дідовським.
Я люблю це.
Це такі є аури,
що трапляються тільки під час фестивалю.
І ми шукаємо це, інколи така думка...
Люди кажуть: «А де ми є? Де фестиваль?
Де, що, які плани?».
Половина каже: «Чекай, це просто якийсь гурток,
зібралися [люди] в дворі, хіба це фестиваль?».
І ми хочемо, щоб було то все,
але він не іде просто так.
Певний дух фестивалю має бути,
а коли той дух з’являться з певних компаній,
які мають цей дух, або дуже хочуть це,
або є виконавці і знають як [майстер клас із]
танців проводити для інших — тоді буде, буде.
[лунає інструментальна музика]
Центральна тема — кобзарська, бо я кобзарюю,
і це моя тема і це мої мастер-класи.
Але останній два роки ми почали
кобзарювати по світу
і це досить серйозний крок для нас,
бо я готуюся до того часу.
Кобзар — це той, хто кобзарює, це той, хто йде
з інструментом і співає там, де його буде чутно на весь світ.
[грає на гітарі]
У мене є учениця з Донбасу. Красива, маленька.
Дівчина, Таня Герасимова.
Вона грає на бандурі. Брала її до Китаю,
Фінляндії, всюди, — і кобзарює.
Вже 10 років.
Вона їде до Фінландії, грає на вулиці. А Джон гастроював
у Фінландії за запрошенням. І вони подружилися.
[англійською] Вона показала мені цей чарівний інструмент,
схожий на арфу, — бандуру —
[англійською] та сказала, що змайструвала його сама.
[англійською] Також, що ось тут у Крячківці живе її вчитель,
який показав, як це все робиться.
[англійською] То ж я захотів поїхати до нього з візитом.
Вона телефонує мені.
«Юрко, можна я приїду з американцем?»
«Звичайно, приїжджай.»
Сідаємо в автомобіль і я питаю у Джона звідки він.
[англійською] Я кажу: «Оу, я з південного сходу».
Бо ж, знаєте, в Америці це не дуже важливо, звідки ти саме.
[англійською] А він запитав, а з якого саме міста?
І я відповів: «Із Чапел Гіл». Він перепитав: «Чапел Гіл?»
«О, а я з Роли». Це сусіднє місто.
Ну як можливо? Чому це взагалі?
[англійською] Це було дуже дивно,
дуже надзвичайний збіг,
[англійською] приїхати сюди,
у село в Україні та зустріти того,
[англійською] хто був у всіх тих самих місцях
у Північній Кароліні, що і я, в моєму рідному місті.
[англійською] Це було взагалі нереально.
То ж ми швидко стали друзями.
І я чув як Джон грає, і я був вражений.
Він має кобзарський дух, але кобзарства не знає.
[англійською] Я завжди любив арфи.
Коли я граю на гітарі, я іноді намагаюсь грати наче на арфі.
[англійською] Мені дуже подобається,
як усі струни дзвонять разом.
[англійською] Раніше я ніколи не чув бандуру або кобзу.
[грає на гітарі]
Тут можна грати без колонки,
і це прекрасно звучить. Тут все прекрасно.
Тут не треба маси людей,
тут має бути ідеальна [кількість] людей.
Для них ти щось граєш, вони слухають —
виходить справді камерне дійство.
І вони оцінюють це, вони люблять це.
Для нас це класно!
Це може виглядати дивно для сторонніх людей.
Але насправді, коли сторонні [люди]
повертаються додому, вони:
«О, чекайте — це було дивно,
але так класно, я ще раз приїду».
[грає інструментальна музика]
І досвід каже, що тут є дуже унікальний андерґраунд,
підземний, альтернативний фестиваль,
альтернативна програма —
звісно ж, не така, як совєцька програма.
У нас [в УРСР — прим.] уже був формат совєцький,
той що тут кругом є, для чого тут теж?
Ми хочемо щось українське,
авангард український, сучасний.
То були крячківські кобзарі, Іван Крачковський.
Крачковський. Хто це був? Не знаю,
але це мені здається, що це ще козацьке барокко.
Чи таке було, тут були пани Липський, пан Закревський:
чи вони слухали барокко, ну класику — слухали.
Що ще можна зробити? Робити фестиваль
без формату, без годинники, без розкладів,
без шоу, без цих спотворених моментів.
І ми досягаємо цього. Я би сказав,
що це кобзарування, що відбувається тут.
Це є найкращі умови.
[лунає інструментальна музика]
— Добрий день.
— Добрий день, добрий день.
[російською] Ніно Петрівно, станьте.
Я не люблю формальні промови.
Тут музикують ті, хто хоче, де і як вони хочуть.
Представляти не треба?
Всі знають крячківське «Древо», так?
Якщо ні, ось вони.
♪ Ой у полі древо, ♪
♪ Що тонкоє да й високоє... ♪
Немає кращого плану як має бути.
Колись я планував, [але зараз все інакше].
Зараз план такий: я прокинуся вранці
і спитаю чим я маю зайнятися сьогодні.
І я займуся тим, що вважатиму за потрібне.
Якщо не вистачить часу, тоді [перенесу] на завтра,
на наступний тиждень, місяць, рік.
Це інша філософія. Філософія, що тут
з’являється у мене, — то є для мене навчання.
Фестиваль має своє життя.
Я допоможу чим зможу, я люблю це [фестиваль],
я маю ідеї як це зробити.
Але ми разом цим займаємося.
Я не створював це, я не ідіот.
Ми створили це.
Диви, там без нас щось відбувається.
Вишуканий концерт Джона Вестморленда.
Я не казав: «Давай, Джоне, грай нам цілий день».
Ні, люди прекрасно знають,
ці музиканти, ці творчі люди...
Вони прекрасно знають, коли, як і що [грати],
бо це кобзарська філософія.
[англійською] Як на мене, це країна можливостей.
Як раніше казали, що Америка — країна можливостей.
[англійською] Це не можливості для кожного, але для тих,
хто тяжко працює, відкладає гроші, має хороші цінності.
[англійською] Протягом кількох останніх років я усвідомив,
що важливо досліджувати своє коріння та звідки ти.
[англійською] Очевидно, що Юрій повертається до України,
хоч і народився в Америці, адже його сім'я походить звідси.
[англійською] Це те, звідси походить його родовід.
[англійською] Мені видається красивим,
що він допомагає воскресити традиції,
[англійською] котрі глибоко притаманні українській культурі.
[англійською] У нас були гроші, ми жили
у чотириповерховому будинку, мали кілька машин.
[англійською] Байдуже, це все не так важливо.
[англійською] Адже в Америці у нас не було того,
що ми маємо тут [в Україні].
[грає на інструменті та співає]